steven soderbergh mentioned in his
latest talk at the San Francisco
International Film Festival that it
doesn't matter if your film cost 5
million or 50 million it still costs
about 70 million in marketing and
distribution to do a wide enough release
to recoup costs John why do independent
filmmakers continue to push for
theatrical distribution when it's clear
they do not have 70 million dollars to
compete in the theatrical market well I
would say to that that that's a very
limited conception as to release
opportunities you know that you know yes
he's talking specifically about a studio
release pattern and yeah I'd agree it
probably constantly 70 million dollars
to engage a studio release pattern but I
think most filmmakers when they want a
theatrical release you know independent
filmmakers aren't thinking about that
but I still what I think is important to
think about is to get out of that
theatrical mindset you know and to think
in this is something I wrote in the book
that think about that it's a live event
it's an event it's not theatrical or not
the optical or anything of the standard
terms that come from the studio world
and screw the studio world it's like
you're an artist and you're creating a
certain kind of content you're engaging
audiences in a certain way and one of
the ways that you can engage audiences
through events and foremost independence
a traditional theatrical doesn't make
sense you know what events make sense so
to think about why filmmakers want a
theatrical release when they don't have
70 million dollars is almost a straw man
article argument because that's not even
the question the question is what kind
of release makes sense for your
particular film and the craft or release
that does make sense for your film and
usually there's some kind of event
component that does make sense for your
film it just depends on the particular
film that's going to inform what kind of
event component that is to call
filmmakers out for wanting to do a 70
million dollars theatrical
release i think is potentially unfair
we're not even not unfair it's just not
the right issue I think the issue is
that how our filmmakers going to engage
their audiences and may cause audience
is interested in their in their work and
and that's the more interesting question
you